my name is alicia williams and i'm a
gravestone conservator
today i'm going to show you how i clean
gravestones
before i start a clean i take the time
to assess the gravestone
and i make sure that it's not wobbly or
in any way deteriorating before i
approach the clean
the next step would be to apply a
product called d2 biological solution
it's been tested and shown to be safe
and effective at removing all of the
biological growth on the surface of a
marker and it doesn't cause any harm or
leave behind
any residual damage or effects like
bleach wood or
regular household soap i soak the whole
marker
and then i will allow that to dwell on
the surface
for a few minutes and i will spray it
down with a little water
d2 keeps working over time that's how
it's formulated the warmer it is outside
the better it works
i personally find the fall is my
favorite time to go clean because
the d2 works throughout the winter and
so when you come back in march
april it's just an entirely new piece
[Music]
this particular marker had a significant
amount of
mossy growth on the surface of it it was
a very satisfying scrape
for me i am scraping the lychen
and surface debris off of this stone
before i begin the brushing process
lychen is just like little mossy
flowery growths that kind of stick onto
the surface
they're harmful over time they will
completely overtake the stone
the type of grime and dirt that's on a
gravestone varies depending on
where you're located and where the grave
itself is is it under a tree is it in
the shade
is it on a hill like does it get any sun
it's mostly different types of lightings
and moss
and just dirt and grass and
things that get blown on it from mowing
and caretaking efforts
i am using a regular bamboo skewer that
you would buy at your local grocery
store to make sure i get all of the
debris out
occasionally i will pull those out to
facilitate the cleaning process
the main type of brush that i use is
called a tampico brush
it is made with natural bristles and as
you scrub
the stone the bristles just get softer
so
it really limits any abrasion to the
surface of the marker
some of the smaller ones that i use the
bristles will wear away
instead of the stone itself so i'll wear
them down to almost nothing and
throw them away
generally speaking if you wouldn't use
the brush
to wash your car you don't want to use
it on a gravestone
anything harder than that is going to
possibly
risk harming the integrity of the stone
or the inscription itself
i do not press hard it's pretty gentle
if it's a newer
polished granite marker you can be a
little bit more aggressive with those
because
it's a stronger stone and typically
they're modern and able to withstand a
little bit
more than the older ones
once i feel like i've gotten the bulk of
it off then i give it a good rinse
and let it dry
it's very important to keep water on the
stone while you work
because keeping the stone wet as you
scrub limits any abrasion to the surface
and
it also helps whatever is on there to
come off a little bit more easy
i carry a lot of gallons of water with
me
a low pressure sprayer that's important
because on historic stones
they're a softer stone marble sandstone
and they're
very easily damaged by high pressure so
it's important to use a low pressure
sprayer
like what you would use to spray
fertilizer on your garden plants
the most important tip i have for
someone who wants to get started in
cleaning gravestones is to
remember the main principle is to do no
harm and to
ask permission before you work in any
cemetery
the excitement of watching that first
stone come clean
was the first time i felt like a real
genuine
smile come up on my face and a really
long time
it just made me feel really good inside
like i had found a purpose